[Musik]
ihr
doppelt so viel mehr muskeln wie normale
fragen will sie reinheit und strahlt vor
ihnen und die hat will die reinheit im
meer ist nicht vorhanden und downloads
österlich baustelle
es dauert jeden tag drei stunden bis
sabine bühner glaubt sich den menschen
außerhalb ihrer wohnung zumuten zu
können
mir
hat ein arzt will jedes falsche oder
yeti wintro in die falsche richtung
könnte stören sie
ich bin
magersüchtige wo vor dem spiegel steht
und stolz ich auf mein apple noch auf
sie und ich glaube es für mich viel mit
angst sich spieler und
spieler augen muss sich vorstellen wir
hatten mal schwitzten inneren mal oder
hat gespürt die behaupten körperwärme
will ich war ja nicht an die trolle
über
125 jahren cash poker team das ich weiß
gar nicht wie das schmeckt
man jetzt so
entlassen und der gibt mir war und ich
würde bis zu spüren das macht mir angst
[Musik]
ich bin immer sehr leid ist die
einsamkeit und gleichzeitig einen
vertrag ab sich nun und ganz schwierig
daran gar nicht gern alle sorten des
kartells viel glück hat und die schliche
nicht einfach unter der masse
untertauchen
unter beachtung schenkte warum und dann
kann ich nicht einfach miserabel
aber bestatter spielklasse und intellekt
buch und ja noch nicht ans klasse
auf und so was cleese asse und vor allem
viel trinkt vaters nimmt
all das was einem normalen menschen
struktur gibt ist für sabine bühner
fremd und bedrohlich mahlzeiten zum
beispiel sie ist erst nach einbruch der
dunkelheit und nur allein in ihrer
wohnung ein brötchen und einem joghurt
maximal 700 kalorien täglich
einer geregelten arbeit konnte sabine
bühner noch nie in ihrem leben nachgehen
ihre aufgabe ist das überleben ihrer
vergangenheit ihre welt sind
bibliotheken die täglichen telefonate
mit ihrer mutter und arztpraxen
noch sehr viel die es sich um vom
terminator kinder beim ihnen ärztekammer
- und wollte
mich aber dann
traf
das sind die us-stützpunkte nicht
getroffen sich dabei wahrscheinlich
andere einmal im jahr zum doktor könnte
ich ja zwei drei mal in der woche oder
und das ist für mich mehr soziale netz
und
betrieb für andere familien unter
sabine bühner ist 41 jahre alt 28
kilogramm schwer und 141 cm groß die
masse einer untergewichtigen
zehnjährigen
es probleme ziehen sich wie ein roter
faden durch ihr leben schon mit acht die
erste magersucht ihre reaktion auf die
schwierigen familienverhältnisse in
ihrem elternhaus dass ich das wohl
mancher kontrollieren um noch an st ich
esse so viele dass sie am
lageberichte sterbebett ich nicht aber
ich weiß genau wie viel kilo dass ich
darf sie damit ich nicht irgendwelchen
traffic führung und ich bin mir jetzt
bei sony netzwerke besser 28
mit acht jahren die erste mit 13 die
zweite magersucht ein schutz gegen ihre
kunst von trainer der sie jahrelang
sexuell missbrauchte
muss ziele mit 3 6 7 5
und 6 asse und bürger einig li und
angibt dann wird er ganz in der nähe
sehen scheinen mir bringen mich ganz
besitzer quasi
und das ist für mich einfach wie ein
rettungsanker xxi so wird er könne
ja mich ganz oder alles half mir
gedanken eines kindes in not in den
gerichtsakten wird später von
jahrelangen penetration versuchen des
trainers die rede sein
die 13 jährige sabine hörte auf zu essen
und blieb tatsächlich klein
freiburger ist doch lee will ccs der
magersucht das haben wir nicht wachse
der markt sucht hat sie sind die welt
kostet wir viel mehr hat noch eine
zeigen ihnen arbeit bis zu zehn
zentimeter das ist einmal der erste teil
und das war's ich sowieso fliehen wurde
aber
ziemlich lassen was durch markus macht
er klar bärisch und denn müssen rascher
ist ganz klar durch die missbrauch
situation durch den stress durch der
missbrauch über touren durch das ist der
raster bedingt
professor usa holzer spezialist für
wachstums- und hormonstörungen
er konnte schon die achtjährige
magersüchtige sabine damals schickte er
mutter tochter und stiefvater in eine
familientherapie
im jahre 1999 als sabine bühner stone
trainer der prozess gemacht wurde
verfasste er ein gutachten über ihre
kleinwüchsigkeit und ihre körperliche
entwicklungsstörung es zeigte auf wie
extrem sabine bühlers körper auf die ihr
zugefügten seelischen und körperlichen
grausamkeiten reagierte
japan ihre jungen aus tanks und ich habe
mir seminar hormon spezialisten chef der
fall boere klare und jetzt passiert das
gleiche wie viel ich den normal und wird
zuerst passiert es hat keiner verstanden
wie er warnt sie denen das mitbringen
wird über über bringen was da passiert
ist mit mit herkömmlicher endokrinologie
mit hormon wissenschaft ist das ganz
schwierig das taxi das ist wirklich und
trumpf und jetzt passt die nation dass
ich psychosomatik in reinkultur und
vermietungen in reinkultur in absolut
extremsituationen macher der fall nur
verstehen wenn es rückzug von der
hormone und zur stück von der
psychiatrie
mitbringt und eine sehr viel weiß über
psychosoziale richtig vor der pubertät
[Musik]
der weg für die missbräuche an sabine
bühner wurde schon früh geebnet der
leibliche vater verließ tochter und
mutter als sabine fünf jahre alt war
sabine suchte einen neuen vater und fand
diesen im neuen partner der mutter ihren
stiefvater
doch als dessen leibliches kind geboren
wurde glaubte die kleine sabine einen
weiteren vater zu verlieren sie litt
unter dem liebes verlust und wehrte sich
mit essens verweigerung in all dem
schmerz tauchte auf einmal ein neuer
mann in ihrem leben auf
[Musik]
ich bin trainer brand in einer turnhalle
und als so witzig gemacht und als
kompliment macht das mit hübschen gut
sind und das hat er mir ein kunde sich
ganzen lässige
die schmeicheleien des charismatischen
kunstturn trainers fielen auf
fruchtbaren boden
sabine suchte die nähe zum neuen idol
und schaffte die aufnahme ins turm kader
dass er trainierte 15 stunden pro woche
hüten sie sich fortan ab um ihrem
trainer zu gefallen der neue mann in
ihrem leben stellte das in aussicht
wonach sabine immer gesucht hatte
anerkennung eine vaterfigur eine familie
ja sicher
dass morgen so unbeschwert ist sie das
aber nie schön und wir uns lustig und
müssen den familien und mehr als gut um
mitglieder sammeln
die erst über vorgestellt sie wurde
mittels dusche da bin ich lang bestanden
und annette dasch und für die andere vom
dorf selber gern das soll natürlich
mitgemacht und bin ich mir wirklich sehr
deplatziert vorhand hat also sowie nicht
ob ich will ich die brüder oder wie mein
stiefvater mir so bleibt hat die
schritte gegangen
habe mich viel geld das ich
bin also hat der brief recht k und ihrem
fehler gemacht beim steve partie
das extreme
das berührt werden sich ansonsten immer
wieder gegangen notiert das jeden tag
für stück
und wenn das halt so schlich und sehe
ich das also
schwierig sieht es mit dass immer wieder
als grenze beschäftigt
der weg von sabines elternhaus zur neuen
trainingsanlage war lang anderthalb
stunden hin anderthalb stunden zurück
immer öfter übernachtete die damals
zwölfjährige deshalb bei ihrem turm
trainer und späteren peiniger bald schon
wohnte sie immer von donnerstag bis
montag bei ihm
besteht das ist
armselig seien
extra kick musik potter kam ist unklar
dann plötzlich gott berufen und ihnen
steckt auch mit wonne schlingt sich um
mich streit um macht und ich glaube
viele situationen und ich habe auch mit
ganzen heiße suppe und probierte es
kommt und ist dank
keine können
die welt befinde mich heute schule
bin schon jetzt suchen dann die tätigen
durfte sie unter druck
minimax im islam
sie hat ihnen erlaubt wie ein vater wäre
freund später wenig lebte wie er alles
und sie hat überhaupt keine chance
irgendwie er die stadt mache jetzt unter
zuerst über halb kaputt geht kann wenn
macht mir die stadt zwar sind ältere
inter pubertät was es ist quasi und das
ist das ganz speziell an ihrer auf immer
und ewig damit der xv lexi
[Musik]
situation ist so extrem dass sie sich
wie mir das vor der
konzentrationslager
deutschland oder dem
balkon dass sich die opfer mit dem
falter identifizieren also es hat gar
kein stacheldraht braucht wie sie gar
nicht auf die idee war fünf meter vor
dem mister exakt so wie sie alles da und
nacht durch erforschten sinne des wortes
tag und nacht wähler machen was er vor
ihrer wälder hat uns immer wieder in der
situation die nummer wasser an bord
sondern was sie denkt dass er will also
im prinzip bestand ist die gt r gehorsam
antizipiert und 100 prozent und danach
die die abhängigkeit schafft der masse
stresst dass wir das wirklich mit dem kz
oder was man mit dem kz dachau
verglichen sind die innere beziehung
zwischen opfer und täter folter und
opfer wohl nach wir werden es so
als folteropfer wird dermaßen abhängig
und wollte dass die innere grenze
zwischen zähne vom opferung screenen
region zu verschwinden und opfer bisher
weiß bastard die volk wünscht hat oder
nicht gewünscht hätte sie sich der masse
mit dem mit dem daad wie denn die tiere
in der situation ist bio logis
es so schnell
hat der us amerikaner
eigentlich gut sie
kann einfach nicht so lang
so
winzig
ich habe mir nie irgendwie so eine
vorstellung aus der optik august haben
gott immer gern und
und einer der weiß sie nur nutzen sein
kann das habe ich mein haus wieder tun
oder sie
stocken
und
das mache ich
natürlich
bewegt kann ich sehen wie klima gegangen
sie haben die
liebe wir nachts
sind sie da durchgegangen und ja das ist
zu hundert prozent
ich bin
sehr optimitisch
strand
und ein halber problem innerhalb
aggressionen
das sind also gut entwickelt
haben sehr große problem dass ich mit
ihnen kann man eigentlich immer wie sich
sagt gesucht und nicht eigentlich
gesucht das könnte prinz
ihre tragische situation
das verbrechen das ein sabine bühner
begangen wurde war auch ein verbrechen
an ihrer mutter sie muss mit den
schuldgefühlen leben ihrer tochter nicht
beschützt so hahn sie hört immer wieder
vorwürfe von sabine und auch sie muss
den vertrauensbruch verarbeiten der ihr
von sabines trainer angetan wurde
mit ihrer gezeichneten tochter hat sie
die schreckliche vergangenheit auch ihre
versäumnisse täglich vor augen
ich bin ja
weniger mich lieben oder die bezirke
weniger
wodka zum mixer sie müssen sie verstehen
sie
und wenn man weiß wie man
selber jahres offiziell erlaubt oder
salbris
dann weiß man das und
das ist das wo man gesagt und das ist
das so wie du wählen was nicht keine
verhindern
ständig
beschäftige er sich selbst nur auf der
sommerbühne
seine vielfach zu glauben ein
mannschaftlich größer ich weiß nicht
oder sind es nämlich die premiere so wie
schaut es nicht so sagen
einzig manchmal wirklich immer für mich
da
schnappe meine ärzte oder so
und das bin ich allerdings sehr rund was
liegt auch noch wie ich mein ich will
mir getrennt andere frühen morgen die
erde
und eigene schau nur sehr und der
porsche
schon im vornherein
weiß man aber ich brauchte nicht im
moment
alles klappt so schwedische langen
dass das nicht stimme wieder blüht
geschäftsbericht
jetzt machen wir alles zusammen
das verbrechen zieht immer weitere
kreise
über familien über generationen
keines der opfer kommt zur ruhe der
anstoß zu diesem fehlen kampf und sabine
bilder selber immer wieder suchte und
sucht sie die nähe zu den medien den
auftritt in der öffentlichkeit um ihre
geschichte zu erzählen
warum kann man sich fragen warum wendet
sie sich nicht endlich von all dem
monströsen ab und der gegenwart
vielleicht sogar einer besseren zukunft
zu
warum erzählt sie ihre traurige
geschichte auch in den medien immer und
immer wieder wenn öffentlichkeit den
start geht die user grenze sie weiß was
außerhalb passiert sich aus sich
heimwerker sie weiter das existiert wenn
wir geschichte alois schnitzer sie wenn
sie innerlich nicht richtig
unterscheidet es tricks und die ihre ist
ja gar nicht so klar bereich existiert
und wie viel anteil für ihre tricks sind
dort verschwindet alles also
öffentlichkeit macht unser ganzes sie
hätten aber versichert im programm sich
alle im programm sie existiert und sie
gesät wie sie existiert auf der einen
seite ist das ein wirkliches sieht es
nicht mehr
sie sind wieder da
die bleiben mir doch es ist wirklich so
glaubt mir
von ihm wieder müsse für größere die
andere sie damit glücklich dass normales
kind
vorstellen missionarin
[Musik]
tierisch auf tod und damit eine zehn
jahren missbrauch verknüpft wäre
passiert sind und sie hunden hier sie
haben mir hoffmann nicht aber sie hund
offensichtlich oder die letzten zwei
jahren nicht wissen wo ihr ganzes labert
reid noch unter summe und das zeigt
nicht das ich stört ist das zeigt wer
massiv druck sich wie massiv das
passiert ist was ihr widerfahren ist
mit 19 befreite sich sabine bühner aus
der totalen abhängigkeit von ihrem
trainer und gab das tun auf das war 1990
damals schaffte sie es gerade noch ihre
kaufmännische lehre zu beenden seither
lebt sie von einer iv wohnt in einer
städtischen einzimmerwohnung arbeiten
konnte sabine bühner nie ihr massives
untergewicht zwangsstörungen
klinikaufenthalte
medikamentenmissbrauch wissen sie nie
einen geregelten alltag leben struktur
geben hier arztbesuche mehrmals die
woche bei psychiatern hormon
spezialisten psychosomatiker
[Musik]
elisabeth bande ist seit 13 jahren
sabine bühlers hausärztin
wisse dass das aber jetzt
schon sagen dass unterricht da ich im
vergleich zum sommer muss ich einfach
nochmal was nicht jetzt drei kilo für
kilo abgenommen dass ich einen zettel
vor ihrem körper durch das ist viel mehr
als das weiß aber mehr so viel abnehmen
meine oper wo soviel medikament braucht
das kommt nicht einfach so sagen das
wäre und sich
auf das
[Musik]
katholische rechte das kalium grund
politisch kindern ist wann das passiert
selten kommunion
[Musik]
sabine bühner war auch schon 17
kilogramm schwer damals hat elisabeth
bahn die sie zwangsernähren lassen ihre
magersucht ist aber nur die eine seite
der schädigung durch den missbrauch
andere emotional instabile
persönlichkeitsstörung und das ist zum
beispiel dann könnte ich kaufe werde
dass man im blau macht ist ein
medikament das man beachten sollten und
dass es einfach nur gott dass sie ihre
sache gemacht wo wir eigentlich mit ihm
zu und man verstanden nicht verstehen
wie man es sei gut wenn sie wenig
kalorien
das wird immer so hoffen die
mini ärzten mit jahrelanger erfahrung
und ich eigentlich in und auswendig
kennt die andere seite ist
sie halt auch
erreichbar ist und ich halt sorgen uster
wo man sie leicht inneren und andere
motive erzählt sie sich ein patient ivo
minar statt wo mir
wo
man so was nicht gleich ist wie sie
ihren gott aber du mich ganz klar ab
ganz und krems telefon und überhaupt
wenn sie mehrere arbeiter das natürlich
ausgesprochen
bronze gewann sie erläutert und an der
spitze
meistens katali also richtig einfach
gern und ich habe man die vorher zu
gehen ich will mich abgaben zivilen eine
rolle übernehme zur stadt dass sich das
neue abhängigkeit gc verwandelt sich ab
als sie mit der ganzen spitzensport
schicht zuschauer extrem abhängig von
ihrer mutter immer noch in 40 das ist
absolut
normale beziehung mutter tochter und ich
will weitermachen das war verheerend und
absolut nicht therapeutisch
sie hätte wenn man körperlich seite
komplette prix click steuerung also das
aber sehr natürliche entwicklungen
gemacht wo kinder zum erwachsenen machen
das ist die direkte folge der missbrauch
und dort damit ist sie natürlich massiv
anders als andere erwachsene wenn man
massiv anders als andere geräte vor
steuer wird verankert und zuwächse ist
sie natürlich sehr stark
persönlichkeitsstörung sie hätten nie
könne
wenn man noch einmal auf pubertät räumen
das ist immer der schlüssel ist inter
pubertät entwickler ja die jungen übt
die erwachsene persönlichkeit also sie
können sie lernen sich ruf gegen
zentrums sie waren abhängig von der
gleichaltrige das ist nach einer
vorübergehenden abhängigkeit und dann
entdeckte sie ihre eigene als ich die
eigenen maßstab
das alles hätte machen also ist es klar
dass die persönlichkeit gestört nur sie
[Musik]
mal bin ich eben mal bin ich die
erwachsene frau aber so ist sehe bin ich
schon sehr nah screen das ist vielleicht
eine schwierige für menschen mit dem
können und auf mich dass ich so bin ich
halt aber ich danke lange spiesse
gorbitz mit dem ich mich aber ich glaube
nicht dass ich das sehr bewusst noch
das kind in ihr verschafft sabine bühner
ab und zu auch ein kleines highlight im
alltag zum beispiel regelmäßige gratis
haarschnitt bei einem von zürich stars
eigentlich gerade das doch ließ war für
probleme 30 mal auf dann haben die
situation erklärt dass ich habe ich mir
gott walther bericht bringenden gute
küche und
ihrem mann geschäftlich soll branchen
mit es heute nacht oder
ja und dann irgendwie im weg was einfach
aussieht und dann sind sehr nächsten mal
mit mir ein problem für bücher und ich
sehe das heute noch nicht wirklich als
das problem oder wenn wir jetzt
vollständig wolle wachsen würde die
schöner finde wenn wir das schöne
dass man die länger sind und das analoge
welt jetzt das midler wachsen
ich will ganz lappen und wohnen und ewig
sie hilft li und
sanktioniert aber die letzte woche in
afrika
trainingslager wo mir nicht beachtet
haben jetzt nach den schlafsack
sabine war nicht das einzige mädchen das
vom selben kunst von trainer total
abhängig gemacht wurde und sich nicht
gegen die übergriffe wehren konnte das
etwa schien lebende mixtur mit dem die
woche
begriff so unscheinbar gefangen ich habe
immer alles normal sie sich nun mag es
ein rollstuhl kroes geht gross
mag dieses oder die lang erwartete kurs
geht
nachher die
talkshows sitzen was ich so eine
steigerung von abnahme
gefühlten
bettina trat als zehnjährige in die
riege des primarius und ton trainers ein
und war den übergriffen schutzlos
ausgeliefert bis sie mit 17 das turnen
aufgabe sieben jahre missbrauch sieben
jahre abhängigkeit
in bettinas sabines und sieben anderen
fällen wurde anklage erhoben die
verhandlung fand 1999 statt die
betroffenen turnerinnen und eine
ehemalige schülerin beschrieben die
übergriffe vor gericht als zungenküsse
regelmäßiges betasten der
geschlechtsorgane über und unter den
kleidern betasten der brüste
die meisten betroffenen brauchten
jahrelange therapien um jetzt zerstörtes
selbstwertgefühl wieder einigermaßen
herzustellen der täter allerdings
bezeichnete sich vor gericht als nicht
behandlungsbedürftig
er zog das urteil weiter bis vor
bundesgericht dort die bestätigung
dreieinviertel jahre zuchthaus für
mehrfache sexuelle handlungen mit
kindern in zwei fällen und mehrfache
sexuelle nötigung in fünf fällen
bettina ist heute 38 jahre alt lehrerin
und mutter von drei kindern sie war es
die 1997 während ihrer ausbildung
zusammen mit sabine bühner und einem
weiteren opfer an die medien gelangte
und den täter so das handwerk legte
in frankfurt dass ich der qualität
setzen sich in besitz zu mehren
aber andere mitglieder erlaube wenig und
ich kann das ich kannte mal und ich habe
größte maßnahme
in die höhe zurück danke den kunden
immer wieder so dass sie in zehn
verlorene kindheit
gestohlen worden ist
[Musik]
sind es ist so wenig druckt allen
kontinenten gesehen ich einfach nochmals
corner der missbrauch und dem awo maxi
und mini
der täter ein allseits beliebter lehrer
aus einer alteingesessenen familie mit
allen eltern per du ein kinder nach hieß
es in der dorfgemeinschaft
es gab einen sehr zaghaften
ausbruchsversuch von bettina eines
ordens eröffnete sie ihren eltern der
trainer habe sie angefasst sie werde ihn
zur rede stellen
mehr sagt der bediener nicht mehr
wollten die eltern auch nicht wissen
obwohl der trainer die tochter nach der
aussprache sogar nach hause begleitete
ihn später kathi muss zehn mit
verschworen und den mag ich mich einfach
nur 110 erinnere dass sich computer
wieder abgegangen bin eigentlich in
ökologischen oder nicht erstaunlich hp
schauen
und dann dank der hund trifft um
71 auf schutz vor minen ältere und dann
sagte ich habe mich aber das ist
wirklich schlimm
der vorfall das einfach die ganze
familie schlussendlich
betroffen ist und das ist ganz schwierig
ist zum
zum der weg gemeinsam also dass
eltern oft nicht amtliche punkt stand
wie screens stellen wenn sie
wenn sie aufstehen darf maria
regina 37 jahre alt mutter von zwei
kindern pflegefachfrau ihr erging es wie
bettina ihre eltern wollten gar nicht
wissen was der tochter in den unzähligen
turnstunden und in den trainingslagern
über lange jahre hinweg angetan worden
war
ich hab's wahrheit ich meine einfach
wahnsinnig schmerzhaft und wahnsinnig
große und unschön und mir bots einfach
weg rechnet sie
und meint einen teil der hose und meinte
ich muss halt einfach oder mehr
wirtschaft einfach und
es kommt aber einfach nicht weg wenn man
alle mit
den sexuellen missbrauch habe sie
verarbeitet sagt regina leben muss sie
aber mit der ungeheuerlichkeit dass ihre
eltern bis heute sehr eng mit dem in der
zwischenzeit verurteilten kinderschänder
verbunden sind
seit er wieder auf freiem fuß ist
verbrachten reginas eltern sogar ferien
mit den täter
die christen haben ist folge aus
für meine familie
und für mich als
ausrede von ihnen ehrlich das ist
stolz vom längsten
behauptet
oder beschädigte mit uns gar
nicht
mal so schlecht
in den strafbestand
mit sogar
das hört auf
das verbrechen das vor über 25 jahren
stattfand zieht seine kreise bis in die
gegenwart der täter hinterlässt
zerrüttete familien zerstörte existenzen
im nachhinein machen der nasse
zwangsstörung sich immer wieder was 23
und risiken bringen
nun ein dunkle du
schreist du gar nur 0 05 spital will
morales trick
große gefunden hat wo man ausscheidet
die bkw
150 mal teppich starb sogar eine salbe
doof gelaufen ist und
mit dem kopf
schon eingeschlafen
erzählt braun der besser gemacht
könne
ich konnte ihn ihren apple und ich muss
mir immer nur schlecht
ich muss jetzt halt
20 jahre psychotherapie liegen hinter
sabine bühner sie sagt sie habe
fortschritte gemacht ihr gewicht pendelt
immer um die magischen 28 kilogramm vor
drei jahren dann die nächste
unfassbarkeit mit 38 kam sabine bühner
in die pubertät
für mich ist sehr schlank sie ich habe
es vor kurzem in buseck ost west und ich
habe mich auch immer mit derselben
bosenick stufe will ich das wirklich
kosten und perioden aurich sehr stark
und wie das halt typisch faulig ist und
ich bin sehr verärgert sie mit dem
körper dass er jetzt einfach macht das
bis jetzt nicht hin unter kontrolle
mit acht richtig dass gehört dass ich
auf der einzige der mich fasziniert mit
natur funktioniert das es muss ihre
besser gange sie also sie der therapie
account sie hat fortschritt machte
bleiben und das hättet weg führt dass
sie im zuge einer völlig falschen
zeitpunkt noch
wachsen körper gelegt hat das wachstum
ist verbietet gewachsen
aber hoffentlich unglaublich verliebt
sie wählen ja relativ gut und hätten
irgendein geschätzt und da hat mich der
stimme um ross prozent sehr
gentleman auf die wunderschöne frau kann
nur bislimi rogen als jetzt und ich
nennt ihn will platz nahm und das sehr
america ganz intelligent und das
imponiert mir
mit einer p roma klassen platten kauft
und verkauft lassen und ein neues papier
unterhaltung lieferte einzig dass auch
sie ist ungewöhnlich
einzigartig ideale und wenn man bedenkt
wie viel grässliches jahren getan worden
ist wenn man die rolle bedenkt die ihre
eltern gespielt oder eben nicht gespielt
haben und was ihr von diesem kunst
hometrainer furchtbares angetan worden
ist in anbetracht all des unerfreulichen
dass ihr zeit ihres lebens angetan wurde
ist sie noch viel bemerkenswerter
elliott ist 68 jahre alt schriftsteller
und architektur professor aus new york
kennengelernt haben sich die beiden in
einem zürcher café
ja
ich bin kein psychiater ich bin
architekt
sie ist eine 40-jährige frau und ich
hoffe dass es in dieser stadt einen
jungen mann gibt der intelligent und
feinfühlig genug ist um ihre qualitäten
zu sehen
dass du mir weh dass sie alleine ist
denn sie hat viel zu bieten auf ihrem
leben fehlt nur etwas liebe viel liebe
sie braucht viel liebe damit die wunden
heilen können die ihr durch den
missbrauch zugefügt
sie kann sich nur selber halte
ich kann nur ein freund sei
ihre beziehung hat also keine sexuelle
komponente
wir beide
das grausamste was ich überhaupt tun
können das würde ich nicht überleben und
sie auch nicht stellen sie sich vor es
gibt sie nicht formal und trauer sondern
sie später es verliert sie wie einen
lehrer oder
wenn ich mich verliere oder zu ihnen mal
fand ich mir sexuelle vorstellungen also
das ist
ganz wichtig will
ich kann mir das nicht einmal vorstellen
[Musik]
aesculap klinik in brunnen sabine bühner
leidet seit monaten unter schier
unerträglichen bauchkrämpfen ihr körper
der ein leben lang misshandelt wurde
wehrt sich mit chronischen schmerzen
die freundschaft zu erklärt hat sich
zerschlagen die gründe dafür sollen hier
unerwähnt bleiben beide benennen sie
sehr unterschiedlich sabine bühner ist
wieder allein mit ihren büchern den
ärzten ihrer vergangenheit ich habe also
nicht getrennt - keine fabis zeit die
kann das nachvollziehen dass sehr
wahrscheinlich
der punkt ist jetzt erreicht so einem
großen schritt passiert
am leben bin um mich an die latte
prallte
und auch weg lager bieten lassen aber
halt
andere form gefunden vom labor für
das sogenannte 08 16 uhr zugänglich ist
für mich ist das einzige tragbarer
und was ist mit dem man der sabine
bühner und den anderen opfern all das
angetan hat über ihn darf hier nicht
berichtet werden der täter hat ein recht
auf den schutz seiner persönlichkeit er
hat seine strafe von dreieinviertel
jahren abgesessen er kann es in anspruch
nehmen das sogenannte recht auf
vergessen wenn doch nur sabine bühner
auch davon gebrauch machen könnte
[Musik]